good morning believe nation today's
message is evolved over to you sure well
I mean for we all have to set goals for
ourselves and I mean I planned
destination is to be busy and to you
know adjust to whatever you whatever
you're introduced to and what I mean by
that is ok as an entertainer I started
off I have a singer you know I grew to
become a dancer in a performer after
becoming a performer than I became an
actor after becoming an actor I became
an entrepreneur at to become an
entrepreneur I became an entertainer on
a different level of introducing other
artists then you know after that I
became a mentor you know so I think just
to continue to evolve in a way that is
beneficial for growth of myself and
others my likeness to continue to be
remembered throughout history and
associated with something great for me
you know there's a mantra that I've I've
lived by and it is that the journey of
the destination is really what it's all
about the pursuit is more important than
the actual destination so as long as you
are moving as long as you're working
that is the destination wow the journey
we're really it is simply that the
journey is the destination actually as
long as you're working you're you're
good this is I think one of the most
important lessons for entrepreneurs to
learn because the way that you think
something is going to work out Israeli
the way that it actually works out and
once you get into it and you start
experiencing and start testing and start
talking to people as you change and grow
as a human beings your business needs to
change alongside of you one of the most
important things I think is crucial to
ended as an entrepreneur you need to be
insanely stubborn and flexible you're
stubborn around the why you're stubborn
around the mission you're stubborn
around your one word your stuff word
around your value you're suffering
around the things that really really
really really matter you're stubborn
around the why what you're flexible
around the what and the house because
that's going to change a million times
as you build it up and so if i look at
my career what I've done what's the why
the real wife for me is because in my
first business I struggled a lot I
struggled as an entrepreneur was making
three hundred dollars a month I felt
like garbage I felt like it was I had no
value to give I had the lowest
self-confidence at any point in my life
when I had that first business as an
entrepreneur and when I found my way
through and we had some success and I
sold the business I wanted to make it
easier for entrepreneurs to get through
I didn't want other people to struggle
as much as I had to struggle that's the
why and it's still the y now that was
when I was 22 and how old am I now
almost 37 you know 15 years of the same
why the same driving force to help
entrepreneurs the how the what has
changed it started off with me being a
speaker and I got invited to speak at a
bunch of different events around the
world and it was great and I still do
some a transition to me doing a website
and having the most popular website with
famous entrepreneur stories online it
transitioned to me starting the youtube
channel and making these videos for you
guys they transition to me right in the
book what's the major publishing house
penguin Random House in my head I'm
thinking about having an entrepreneur
cafe a place for entrepreneurs to come
together and work on their business of
it just having to go to a regular coffee
shop that's designed for entrepreneurs
and there's you know related videos up
on the screen to motivate them and
there's sample business plans to look
through and there's paintings and quotes
at all are related to helping
entrepreneurs I see this vision in my
head of having an entrepreneur
coffee shop at some point we'll probably
get into the FM Carmichael entrepreneur
virtual reality put on your goggles and
experience entrepreneurship you know
it's going to change and it's great and
you need change as an entrepreneur right
if you do the same thing over and over
again you're going to get bored and too
many entrepreneurs get stuck on one
specific execution of the how and the
what and you're locked into one product
locked into one service and then maybe
that even has some success maybe that
starts making you some money maybe that
starts giving you some impact and some
real benefit and then it prevents you
from going out and evolving I can't tell
you how many entrepreneurs I've run into
that are bored of their business and
they want to move on how are you bored
of your business they're bored of their
business because they got stuck on
keeping the same how and what and losing
sight of the why why is always most
important be stubborn around the y and
you'll continue to evolve and have the
courage to introduce new products
introduced in services go in a
completely different direction as long
as it's aligned with your wife so the
question today is I'm curious what your
why is in your business and what your
current what or how is as well leaving
the comments below I'm gonna join in the
discussion I also want to give a quick
shout out to Peter archive Peter thank
you so much for picking up a copy of my
book near one word it really really
really means a lot to me and I hope
you're enjoying the read so thank you
guys again for watching I believe in you
I hope you continue to believe in
yourself and whatever your one word is
much love I'm gonna see you again
tomorrow morning for another shot of
Ventura
I believe nations for those of you who
want a little bit more inspiration on
evolving and how to do it as an
entrepreneur I'm going to include a
couple extra bonus clip that I hope
you'll enjoy when you start trying
different things and you try different
chords or different structures of songs
different beats that you've never really
explored that path before you know and I
think having always been a writer first
I'm obsessed with the syncopation of the
way that words sound when they're said a
certain way and once I've kind of done
something once I always want to go to a
different direction and never repeat
myself so as a writer I think that I've
always hoped that my music would
constantly be changing because you never
want to make the same album twice the
same song twice and you know my greatest
hope has been that as I grow my fans
will grow up with me and as I change and
my life changes my musical change as
well so wish me luck they're clean team
Minaj says I love you but I'm curious
why did you change a rapping style from
the come up days to today I love both
eyes I think I changed my rap style I
[Music]
think you guys were just starting to
hear me and you didn't hear all of me
yet that's it I've always been into
being weird and a little bit but I think
what people really mean is that they
think that I'll change my persona and
and life is about growth and change and
I don't want to be made the same for my
whole life I want to be able to change
and you know I respect the people who
loved you know oh seven Nikki and I'm
definitely going to give you some stuff
and on pain Friday like I'm not
forgetting anybody but i just also have
to meet two to me and the truth is I
started seeing different things I
started going different places I started
eating different things like I can't I
would be fraudulent to wrap the same way
and look the same way an act the same
way because i am not the same period
nada well everyone has their different
belief systems I think everyone has a
different opinions of you know those
types of things that you talked about
certainly as an athlete I kill very much
what I put into my body I think that I'm
38 years old I'm not 22 anymore you look
good you're very sweet thanks but I you
know all those things are important and
all the little things add up to be big
things so when I'm trying to accomplish
things professionally that you know in a
lot of ways you're an unchartered
territory so I've got to do things
differently and I got to evolve over
time I've got the things that may have
worked in the past maybe don't work as
you move forward so the lessons that
I've learned through my own trial and
error I think I'm at that point in my
career I'm very efficient with what I'm
doing so I try to eat healthy I try to
get the right amount of rest I try to do
the right types of exercise I can be on
the field to be available I team I try
to be you know as productive this time
in my career as i was earlier so